I'm joined today by Antonio Garcia
Martinez who's been an adviser to
Twitter head of ads targeting at
Facebook he's also author of the New
York Times best seller chaos monkeys
obscene fortune and random failure in
Silicon Valley which I finished reading
a couple of weeks ago super interesting
book Antonio I mean I think to kind of
set up your experience you you as the
book starts you're working on Wall
Street before you eventually enter the
tech world what was sort of the initial
catalyst for moving from the former to
the latter well the credit crisis right
I mean all of Wall Street was blowing up
right and you know I had a front-row
seat at Goldman to see that happen and
well I've been sort of involved in the
tech scene a little bit I went to school
at Berkeley so I had seen the first tech
bubble kind of grow and to popping you
know in 2001 or so so I kind of knew
that world existed I didn't really know
about it but I knew enough about it to
understand that you know in the future
of financial apocalypse we're all gonna
face it would somehow survive and you
know I think I was for the most part
right at least so far um
so that's that's how it happened and you
know it's it turns out there's actual a
lot of similarities between Wall Street
and some aspects of Technology more than
more than you might think yeah I mean in
the book you you certainly are critical
of some or a lot of what you witnessed
on Wall Street you've also written
critiques into the book about what you
saw at Facebook and in your work in the
startup world etc how much or if at all
was aside from the sort of circumstances
of the credit crisis and leaving Wall
Street how much of it was just not
wanting to be in that world for moral
and ethical reasons if at all oh there
was no there's no ethics to it I mean I
think it was more just Wall Street as a
construct you know it's funny I assume
your viewers are probably familiar with
freakonomics right and you know the
original book by Steven Levitt or
whatever and in which he cites how you
know why is it that so many Chicago drug
dealers are poor or why don't people go
into the drug trade right if they don't
actually the break in life and you know
it turns out you know the attrition rate
is huge one third of them died etc and
so you know there's actually interesting
sort of parallel between Chicago drug
gangs and Wall Street
in the sense that you know initially you
know positions actually are not that
well-paid the more junior roles are
actually not particularly well-paid at
least for the cost of living in New York
and everyone's kind of got you know
running through this kind of dangerous
high-stress thing and the hoax of
becoming getting made so to speak or
becoming a partner right
the only they're the only real out from
Wall Street is pretty cool in the case
of Goldman is making partner and so yeah
I just wasn't willing to sign up for
this sort of you know everyone run
towards you know the machine-gun nest or
whatever and when I used will survive
and now and that's the only hope but in
the meantime you're gonna hate life
which is more or less what Wall Street
was but I mean none of it really didn't
have anything to do with I'd say with
the moral the ethics of Wall Street what
would keep you from going back to that
world now well they wouldn't I don't
know I just it would just it seems
horribly dull I I don't know I still
have some friends were in that world and
I just don't understand how they spent
so long inside of it
um I think Wall Street serves a function
role I'm not anti Wall Street I think it
actually serves a critical function
economy and I'm glad that I worked there
right I mean Mark Twain has this famous
quote a classic is a book that you like
to have read but you don't want to read
right and so I I think you know working
at Goldman Sachs is something that I
like to have I like the fact that I did
it I'm not a big fan of doing it again
to be honest in the second part of our
interview I want to dig more into the
specifics of the ad world and your work
at Facebook working on ads but before we
get into that I'd love to ask you about
your insights in terms of you know I
think there's a perception from many
people that big corporations are sort of
inherently bad and there's other people
that for political reasons see big
corporations as inherently good or sort
of like the drivers of growth employment
and and innovation and everything that
is good in a capitalist society can you
talk about whether that's even a
legitimate sort of dichotomy to discuss
or whether really we're talking about
organizations that are made up of people
and have sort of circumstances put
people in positions where they end up
making decisions they might never even
really think they'd have to make until
they're they're really in the middle of
it in some of the situations you
described
yeah I mean I you know yeah I think one
of the great fallacies of human thinking
is false dualities right of either us or
them or this is inherently good and
that's always inherently evil at big
corporations you know I you know I'm
somewhat skeptical of sort of modern
tooth and nail capitalism I don't and I
guess corporations are in some sense are
the handmaidens of that but I you know
corporations can take various forms and
then corporations can be evil sometimes
and good other times you know I don't
know it's it's hard in Silicon Valley
because a lot of what our corporations
even corporations that are worth quite a
bit I mean Facebook now is worth I mean
like half a trillion dollars you know
when I was there which wasn't that long
ago it still felt relatively small
actually and you know I wouldn't say
chaotic necessarily but often very
improvisational right well then more I
might have not even asked the question
in his clear of a way but imagine for
example a controversial decision that a
company makes about you know selling
people's data to advertisers for example
or something like that and immediately
there is or sort of general assessments
made of that's a really bad company that
did that and then when you break it down
really it's sort of like the culmination
of a lot of little decisions many of
which you described in the book chaos
monkeys little decisions that build on
top of each other motives that build
over time until you really have mostly
what what I would consider good people
but this inevitability of making the
bigger picture decision that's often
framed as a bad one it's not a defense
of corporations but I'd be interested in
hearing from you how those dynamics
develop inside of a company yeah I mean
I guess yeah I don't have much you're
citing that data thing is just a
particular example or you specifically
want to get into that no no it's just a
random one something that might be
controversial is portrayed in corporate
media for example
yeah but corporate media is kind of
stupid right I mean I think most Tector
yeah most tech journalism is terrible
and is written not I think that there
definitely is good tech journalism
obviously right and I think the best
tech journalism is sort of a very
informed popularization for Ames
partially both at insiders and also at
outsiders to understand that world I
think the bulk of sort of mainstream
tech coverage is either gee whiz look at
this cool gadget in the most superficial
way or I think
you just described which is a very
popular narrative around Facebook which
is probably why you're citing it would
you so look at this evil thing they're
selling our data I mean the funny thing
is it's not even true I mean Facebook
doesn't sell your data anyone who claims
Facebook sells your data doesn't
understand how Facebook makes money and
so that you know that that's kind of and
again I'm the first one to say and I
criticized Facebook in many ways in the
book part of these and why I wrote the
book I said I just you know Facebook was
one of those things we will to
definitely question and think about and
wonder but you know I kind of wanted
them to ask the right questions in many
ways and I think often in the case of
Facebook and I assume more broadly
although I'm not really an expert about
those other companies you know they're
often not discussing the right things or
they're not worried about the right
things frankly I think I think it was
just because some of these fields are so
technical or so new it's really
difficult to understand how they work I
mean I myself before I went to Facebook
wouldn't have understood how a 2 billion
user company actually monetizes itself
and so again I'm empathetic with with
those views in a sense but I I'm
empathetic but I I would hope to engage
with them and kind of remedy them today
there's I'd be curious to get your
assessment as someone who has worked at
some of the more well-known tech
companies but you also built and
participated in the in the sale
acquisition of smaller companies how
much of the success of some of these
tech companies is due to just the idea
is extraordinarily good compared to I
guess what i would put under the
umbrella of chance an under chance i
would include where it is that you
happen to start the company and how that
connects to the people that you meet the
timing of when it is that you decide to
start creating or executing this idea
other items that you would put under
under the the umbrella of chance do do
you have a sense of how that split might
work out in the real world yeah i mean
it well the idea it's up is worth noting
I mean if and if you know if you doubt
that then go and try to sell one and see
what they give you for it right I mean
idealisms worth almost nothing in
Silicon Valley what's worth something
and why you know relatively small
companies well small companies I you
know embryonic companies that don't
really exist yet get funded or gets
older in the case of mine getting sold
10 months after it was founded is
because two things one even the team
which is always very important in
Silicon Valley or execution right it's
very rare
an idea in and of itself to be worth
almost anything um but you know but just
to kind of maybe slightly more of your
question I think you may be asking is
what what how much is value accrues to
happenstance right being in the other
place right I'm versus you know actual
willful action on the part of the team
whether that's due to their talent or
the execution or the seed ID or whatever
right um you know it's a good question I
I think you know neither is really
neither is really sufficient and both
are necessary and so I think it takes
both I mean I a lot of people have this
conversation in Silicon Valley sort of
behind closed doors because everyone
wants to believe that it's it's a strict
meritocracy but anyone that's been in it
long enough realizes that of course it
isn't and everyone in Silicon Valley has
you know met the guy who built a
wonderful product was an amazing
engineer and yet for x y&z reasons never
quite managed to monetize it or have a
big exit and then we've all met that guy
who was an early employee at Facebook
who basically won the job lottery
mediocre engineer no big deal almost got
fired there when he was there or
whatever and then walked away with you
know fifteen million dollars when he was
25 or something we've all seen those
stories and so you know I I don't know
putting a number on in half and a half
who knows I mean I think both are
necessary that's the reality of it you
do need the luck and the heavens dancing
you also need the talent I think most of
the time unless somebody wins the
lottery which which also happens but
yeah I mean certainly I think there's a
lot more luck in it put it this way seen
from the outside world right the average
mainstream observer that's looking
valley there's more luck involved than
they think put it that way we've been
speaking with Antonio Garcia Martinez
he's author of chaos monkeys obscene
fortune and random failure in Silicon
Valley we'll take a quick break and
continue with him next I'm continuing my
conversation with Antonio Garcia
Martinez who's been an advisor to
Twitter head of ads targeting at
Facebook also author of the New York
Times best seller chaos monkeys obscene
fortune and random failure in Silicon
Valley I'd love to talk a little bit
about the work you did in ads targeting
at Facebook and ideally make this as
interesting as possible for people who
may have a sense of the degree to which
ads are being targeted to them on
Facebook and elsewhere on the internet
but might not really understand sort of
the underpinnings of it so let's start
there what was like the big revolution
in ads targeting that
you were a part of when you were working
at Facebook well the realization that
Facebook doesn't have much data that's
for one so we spent a year trying to
never one thinks that Facebook has all
this amazing data um the reality is you
know it well there's lot of fallacies we
can attack here in terms of how the
mainstream world thinks about Facebook
but you know one of the big discoveries
was that when I joined him the first day
I joined I fired up the revenue
dashboards and I saw that Facebook's
monetization on a per ad basis was
incredibly low and I which I didn't
quite understand at the time although I
later grew to understand it you know the
time Facebook was making money because a
billion times any number is still a big
number right and Facebook was just
getting so big even if the ads
themselves weren't worth much there's
enough of them that at least initially
it would still make you know a billion
or two dollars a year but if things were
gonna you know really take off there was
gonna be an IPO and you know what
investors expected it would have to do a
lot better than that
right and so yeah the quick realization
was that Facebook cousin actually
actually have data that's actually about
it will to advertisers by and large I
mean there is some that they do have
geography age and gender or certain
extent are important other pieces of
data that most people don't realize like
Facebook knows who you are and every
machine that you touch because Facebook
is so addictive that turns out to be
very important and when it comes to
targeting attribution of ads so there is
some data that Facebook has there's a
big realization that Facebook would
really have to open itself to the
outside world of targeting if it was
really gonna make you know lots of money
and actually you know sometimes service
some of the most sophisticated
advertisers so you know that I think
that was a realization that hit the
company and right around 2012 which is
when they started shipping all these
sorts of new ads targeting products many
of which got plenty of coverage in the
2016 election cuz they were used
extensively then so when you visit for
example a company that makes espresso
machines you visit their website and
then you're on Instagram and an ad for
that espresso machine comes up and
you're on Facebook on your computer and
an ad for that espresso machine comes up
a lot of times people believe that's
because Facebook has all of my data but
the way you explain in the book that
that works if I understand correctly and
if I don't then then I'll be embarrassed
is that it's actually the espresso
machine company that has the data and
they are able to use
Facebook to match that data in a sort of
mathematical way not with you as an
individual named the Antonio Garcia
Martinez or David Pakman or whoever to
target ads to you on the Facebook
platforms is that more or less the way
that it works sort of I mean it is an
exact match it's not probabilistic
they're not using like machine learning
to make them it I mean it use it so yeah
so yeah so basically yes I mean what was
built in 2012 was effectively a join
from what was until then a fairly close
ecosystem of Facebook to the entire
outside world of data that's known about
you as you know a consumer in this
capitalist society right um and um you
know how that happens there's very
second of ways that happens it probably
not worth getting into ear um but you
know the key the key idea to understand
here is that you know one of the
fallacies in thinking about how Facebook
makes money is that Facebook sells your
data right you mentioned this meme
earlier that people like reporting on
it's not really that's not true at all
actually
Facebook for starters doesn't sell your
data it doesn't actually let your data
leave the Facebook ecosystem at all
right um they would be suicidal for it
to do so and so it actually designs
products such that Facebook this does
not link data in any real way
I'm secondly Facebook doesn't actually
sell your data um it actually sort of
buys your data and whatever you buy buys
your data doesn't actually pay money for
it but it builds tools and services and
products such that advertisers are
willing to either share their data or
effectively share their data by
expressing that data on Facebook so
getting back to your example about I
forget what product you name but you
know you're shopping for whatever shoes
some consumer some electronic product
whatever Amazon or Zappos or just the
name random companies um will have
effectively joined that record that goes
through your browser in your in your
cookie record with the Facebook user ID
which is you know your unique ID on
Facebook and that's how they show you
that ad based on that browsing behavior
so Facebook had to build a product which
I helped create called custom audiences
that basically joins that outside set of
data with the Facebook user ID it allows
that advertise you can actually show you
an ad within seconds of you having been
on their page um whether Facebook
actually how much data Facebook actually
gets from that is kind of a longer
question it doesn't get everything I
mean these companies themselves by the
way don't necessarily trust Facebook and
are very jealous
data and so they went off share as
little as possible with Facebook you
know they literally just want to share
as much such like on Facebook figure out
who you are and that's it they don't
want to share anything beyond that but
without going into too much detail um
that's the reality of how this Facebook
has to build products so that
advertisers are willing to effectively
share the fact that you went and shop
for a product in the website so that
Facebook can show you an ad so one of
the most popular stated upsides of this
system is that you are going to get ads
that are relevant to your interests you
will have fewer irrelevant ads appear
you won't as a man for example get ads
for a product that is used almost
exclusively by women just like as one
example right one of the general
concerns we hear about these systems are
general privacy concerns but can you
talk a little bit about what some of the
non privacy sort of possible dark sides
of such a system are if you believe
there are any well the dark sizes the
system doesn't work and you see crappy
ads right I mean look here's the reality
in the ads world there's only two types
of ads that seem from the point of view
of the user
they're either crappy and they're
terrible and they're general and back
when I was at targeting p.m. people
would always complain on Facebook
geysers are terrible because it's some
iPad scam or it's some product I'm not
related it's like well okay great so now
we joined your user experience to the
entire outside world of data and now
you're looking at the thing that we know
you that you want that you shop for
literally 30 seconds ago and what and
what's the problem mo suddenly they're
creepy so all ads from the point of the
user either crappy or creepy and there's
nothing in between right I think the
reality is that users are just not
willing to reconcile themselves with the
realities that a consumer internet
product that depends on network effects
like Facebook or Twitter or you know
Instagram or whatever will necessarily
depend on ads as a business model there
have been no other exceptions to that
there's no other company that manages to
be viable and produce a lot of the
consumer internet without ads as part of
its business model well I guess a
concern could be and I'm speaking
hypothetically and you might hear me say
this and say yeah David that's just not
possible based on how the system works I
guess a potential concern would be well
you would be able to triangulate data
such that you are using people's
browsing preferences for products to
identify ways in which they might be on
barely manipulated by propaganda news
into supporting some political thing
that's against their own interests or
something like that I mean I don't know
is that even remotely possible well I I
don't know that the use your browsing
history but the technology of joining
outside data about you that you know
presumably has been legally acquired
right there's an entire secondary market
and data in the US yeah and you and then
using this technology to project that on
Facebook yeah that was used during the
election Trump used custom audiences
like crazy you know a 2016 you know if
you want to sign a moral value to that
because you don't like Trump or whatever
then I guess you can but again you know
I think there's just different
conceptions of privacy in Europe privacy
is seen as a regulatable legislative
thing that underemployed European
bureaucrats constantly going about in
the u.s. it's consumed more of a
consumer choice issue and there actually
isn't that much national regulation um
you may or may not like that but that's
that's what it is in the US right and so
it's seen as a consumer choice issue
where the attitude is basically well if
you don't like Facebook in some sense
targeting you then don't use Facebook
right that's kind of the attitude in the
u.s. um you know I it's weird because
even I'm actually I'm critical of
Facebook in other regards but in this
regard I just a lot of the criticism
advertising I just seem really
unrealistic to me um particularly cuz
there's no alternatives to it I mean how
else is the internet gonna get paid for
right that's the reality of it the user
expectation has been said that things
like Facebook which are very expensive
to actually generate and produce even
though most usually I think that realize
it um how is that gonna actually get
paid for I'm not gonna be membership
fees right we know that no no no yeah I
mean I you can go to all sorts of
reasons why it's never gonna be
membership fees right but it's never
gonna be membership fees hey and it's
funny there's all these rumors like up
Facebook's an attraction for guys but
you know that's the last thing they
would ever do is so ya know I mean this
is the reality and I also I think I'm
gonna sound like a total kind of [ __ ]
about it by saying this but you know I I
find it hard to sympathize with people
who feel so paranoid about the fact that
someone tracked them to sell them a
sweater right I mean you know given you
know if this was like if this was
government monitoring with the NSA or
we're in some sort of politically
unstable State
and it was government monitoring I can
sort of see that but where it's
literally a commercial product
I mean look here's the reality of it and
it's it's totally unfiltered and no
one's gonna like it they're gonna how
long but it's completely true no one
actually cares about privacy I mean a
few privacy advocates that have made
their careers about it care about it but
I can guarantee you everyone who cares
about privacy I give them a twenty
percent coupon off at the gap and you
know they would literally you know sex
being nude photos of themselves like
they don't care her no one actually
cares about privacy and the deep way
that they like they're not gonna use
Facebook because of it I mean know that
I mean that's clearly empirically not
the case Facebook has what 2.3 billion
users and dry so you know I I don't know
I think it's the whole privacy story I
can see it gets you know gets clicks
people are in kind of engage with it I
think every tech journalist is like
legally required to write a one Facebook
privacy story a year or they lose their
drinks or whatever but it's I think it's
kind of a pointless story
I mean Hurdle ism license there's one
that we've heard from the current
president right that's an idea right I
mean you know I think again I think
there's lots of questions and a lot of
objections one can raise my Facebook um
I I don't mean to say Oh Facebook is
perfect just don't ask questions about
it yeah but complaining that things like
retargeting that they've improved your
ads by showing you ads for products you
actually want to you know you actually
want to buy it's some sort of massive
negative I mean sorry no it isn't you're
complaining about the craftiness of the
ads you know three years ago right like
you can never please some some users I
mean you know if you want to ask me like
what are the things that people should
be worried about a little bit I mean
sure in the context of the Russia ad
hacking thing the fact that Russians
were able to buy political ads strictly
speaking that's actually not legal so
political ads actually are regulated in
the US in a way that you know regular
ads are not and you know I think
Facebook does need to change they're a
little bit in terms of how it does
business and that and I think those
complaints are are really justified
because when it comes to politics and
democracy that's just more important
than selling you a pair of shoes and I
and I can totally see that right and so
you know III again and I can rattle off
six different things that people should
be asking questions you know Facebook
questions about but I you know I just
don't think the ads targeting is is one
of those things the book is super
interesting it's chaos monkeys obscene
fortune and random failure in Silicon
Valley I finished it up a couple of
weeks ago we've been speaking with the
book's author Antonio Garcia Martinez
thanks so much for talking to me about
this yeah thank you having